hello and welcome to a video about video
editing with blender that is a tongue
twister
now today we're going to be looking at
transitions this is a continuation of my
previous
videos about blender video editing and
the latest version
2.9 i'm actually on 2.90.1
and let's get started so of course you
want to install an open blender
and then you want to go to file new
video editing
and i'm going to very quickly just out
of habit
set up all this stuff so under my file
format i'm going to change it to ffmpeg
and under encoding i'm going to set my
audio to ac
that's just something you should get
used to doesn't have anything to do with
the transitions really
i'm also going to set my output to where
i like it
just another thing you should do and
then
we're going to save now that we have
that i'm gonna call it transition
cool okay so let's drag in some video
files now of course you can just
go to your file explorer and drag them
in or you can go
up here to this whole thing and do it
now i have a bunch of recordings under
recordings
on my d drive so i'm just going to go
there
and i'm going to grab something i'm
going to scroll way down here
let's grab let's grab this one
and there's my mug zoom it way out let
me uh just hit home here to see the
whole thing
so all we're going to do really is just
look at doing some transitions so i'm
going to just
go over here set an end point now i
haven't set up
proxies on here so it's going to be a
little laggy
but i'll still be able to get the point
across so let me just make some cuts
so when you do transitions it's
sometimes hard to see if it's just
transitioning to a screen that looks
about the same
so let me find something like completely
different and delete all that
delete all that and just press the
delete key after that box select
we want something of the same frame rate
let's see what this one is
okay this is that one about the rock
thing but this will be an easier
transition
so here's what you do you basically have
two different strips right two video
strips
you want to grab one of them uh it can
be either really
uh yeah let's grab this first one and
you want to press
g from grab and then move it
now it's going to lag a little because
it's going to update my video as i move
it
but you want to overlap them on
different levels here
so if you zoom way in you can kind of
see the time and usually around two
seconds is good
but it depends how long you want it to
be i'm going to move my
cursor thing over here that way it
doesn't try to update the video as i
drag everything
so i'm going to grab these again and i'm
just going to do a
grab now i could press x to lock it to
the x so i don't accidentally go up and
down
i'm not too worried about that here so
about right here
is somewhere around about
three minutes 30 seconds so if we want
to go about two seconds we want to go to
332
so about right there so about right
there
so this is an overlap of about two
seconds now what you do is you
select one of the video clips and you
hold shift
and you select the other one and then
all you do
is you press shift a or you go to add
so add transition
now these are the different transitions
there is a cross
which i believe just fades the first one
out
and fades the next one in and a gamma
cross
which actually does more of a video it's
not a fade in and out it's a
it'll look like a fade in and out
usually it looks about the same as the
cross
but this actually fades both the videos
across each other so those will both
look about the same and just do a
slow cross fade where one video kind of
turns into the other
is what it will look like and then
there's also white
we're mostly going to look at wipe
because this is the one that has a lot
of different options so we're going to
click wipe there
and don't just don't forget it's on the
add
transition but you've got to have both
the videos selected
so i'm just gonna do it again the other
way with shift a which brings up the
same menu
transition wipe okay so once you have
this up it default selects the white
but if you unselect it you just go click
it and once you have this clicked
you get the effects over here make sure
you've clicked strip over here at the
top right
although if you're on one of these other
ones you won't see these options so got
to click on strip
there and now you just want to look at
these this effect strip you have an out
and an n
then you have a transition style the
style has single
double iris or clock so let's go ahead
and just click
right here so we can see what our video
looks at this looks like at this time
and as you can see
this is on a wipe and it's out and it's
uh
it's currently half and half with a line
in the middle so if we scroll this over
a little bit we'll kind of see what it's
doing
so it looks like it's just bringing it
down like a blind going down
so you could flip this and it'll flip
the direction it'll be like
it coming from the bottom and
transitioning in from the bottom
so if you want this to go side to side
what you do
is you take this angle and type in 90.
and there you go it's now side to side
and if you want to do a weird angle you
can so you could do like a
i don't know like a 45 degree angle for
example
and then you'll get like a little
sideways 45 degree bar so those are some
cool different ways you can do that
and this line here is just a solid line
but if you change this blur with
it actually makes this line a little
blurry and it can kind of look cool
sometimes
you now this blur is extremely sensitive
so like even with like as
0.02 it is very noticeable
as you can already see i don't know if
you can see with the video quality but
let me zoom it in here it's already
blurry even which is 2.02 so this is
incredibly sensitive blur width so you
can even do like .00 something
and well it's not very noticeable there
but once i even get to .009 it starts to
be
a little more obvious so if you change
this
if you just want to be like oh i don't
know how about like 0.1
that's a pretty massive blur as you can
see
let's take a look at these other ones so
what's double look like
double is like so it just does it
two at a time so on the wipe
out it starts from the middle
and wipes the old one out and if you do
an end
it brings it in from the sides
brings the new one in from the sides
and of course you can play around with
the angle
and the blur width on that too
now let's look at the other ones here
there's an iris
which is basically a center i let me
change let me turn down this blur with
so it's just a solid i and this is an
n so it'll bring the new one in from the
sides which kind of looks like it
swallows the old video or something i
kind of like that one
and you can imagine what out will do
it'll just make it come in from the
center
and kind of look like it pushes the old
video out or something
of course the blur works with those on
those little
lines as well
and there you go all right and the last
one we're going to look at here is the
clock
now this has a in and out
and that's like a clockwise or
counterclockwise type thing
so let's turn this blur down real quick
and we'll take a look so alt
does a counterclockwise
thing where it kind of swipes out the
old video
into the new one and let's look at n
n just goes clockwise it starts from the
three o'clock and just goes around
and there's a blur width on that too
and it just blurs the line just the same
as the other ones
there's some other options down here i
typically don't mess with these
but there is an offset and a crop that
you can play around with if you really
want to get fancy
this just moves this entire piece of
video which i can't imagine using that
in a wipe but
you know maybe maybe you want to for
some reason
so there's a few other things and
there's a color i don't know why
i can't imagine wanting to mess with
these but these are basically the
options you get when you make a
transform layer because this essentially
i think is just a transform layer with
some special properties to have this
extra but the main thing about it is
this effect strip these different
transition types
all right well let me know if you have
any questions about that
i think that's about it yeah you just
sort to recap
you just cut your video you know pick an
area
press k overlap them a couple seconds
you can hold shift here to be super
precise
usually about two seconds is what most
videos and movies do
but you can play around with that maybe
you want it longer or shorter
another thing i'll note is if you go
over here and you do a cut on a strip
that has a wipe on it before it does
this odd thing like this
so you want to get all your cuts sorted
out before doing the wipe
otherwise you're going to get this type
of thing where it seems to want to do it
to the previous video
pretty odd because now we have to
do this sort of thing
bring it back over so that's just
something to keep in mind
i'm gonna hit undo a bunch of times just
to just get your cuts before the wipe
sorted out before
otherwise you're going to have to work
with redoing it basically
i think that's about it see you guys